today children as young as five years
old will begin receiving the covet 19
vaccine in new york city public schools
in san francisco they're soon requiring
kids age 5 to 11 to show proof of
vaccination to enter indoor public
spaces like restaurants entertainment
venues and sporting events fox news
contributor laura trump is here to react
laura what's your reaction
hey good morning ainsley um well gosh
i've never been happier that i moved my
family out of new york down to florida
after you know hearing this and as
though we needed any more reasons not to
visit san francisco what with the
homeless situation uh we know it's nancy
pelosi's district she's done a very poor
job of running it there uh this just
adds another reason to that i think that
you know fear-mongering and fear tactics
have been used from the very beginning
of covid as it relates to children
because they wanted to scare parents and
this is just it feels like a
continuation of that when you look at
the science and you talk to doctors they
will tell you that the seasonal flu is
far more deadly for children than kovid
19 yet ainslie we are not forcing our
kids every year in school to get a flu
vaccine that is an optional thing for
children so why the forced vaccine for
covid19 when we know that thank goodness
covet does not impact kids the same way
it does adults there's a very low
hospitalization rate death rate they are
not the super spreaders that we
initially thought they might be so at a
certain point i think so many people ask
themselves what is this all about and it
feels like it's less about covid less
about safety and more about control
and it's it's as though these people
have learned nothing you mess with the
kids the parents are gonna start pushing
back and i feel like we're gonna see
more of that happen yeah i'm glad you
brought that up that might be why we're
seeing a red wave in our country when
you talk to parents they say these
republican candidates are listening to
our issues here's stephanie cutter she
is a former white house advisor to obama
she was on with chuck todd listen to
what she said about the republican party
the one thing that we need to make sure
that uh republicans in 2022 don't become
is the party of parents
uh because we need to be the party
and and we are we're the ones that care
about school funding we're the ones that
care about making sure that parents can
send their kids to school
because they have jobs to go to you know
all of this we need to own that agenda
we cannot let it go and it's not just
about critical race theory it's a it's
coming out of covet it's parental
frustration it's parents being involved
in their kids schooling
it's a great message isn't it for the
republicans to become the parent the
parent for the parental party
yeah the the party of parents i mean
listen i think that uh she's on to
something there and unfortunately for
her i think it's a little bit too late
unfortunately for the democrats they
have done the same thing that has worked
for them for so long to get out there
the pander for votes we saw in virginia
gosh they brought in the whole slate
with obama with biden with harris they
brought them all out because they
thought gosh what we've always been
doing has been working so well and what
they got it was a real wake-up call and
it was that parents are not buying it
anymore gosh isn't it interesting that
parents don't want their kids taught
hateful rhetoric and school critical
race theory isn't it crazy that they
don't want to be called domestic
terrorists that they want their kids to
live in a safe society a lawful society
so i think there's going to be more
pushback i think it's driven a lot of
people who were independents and some
democrats over to the republican side i
think we're going to see it more in 22
and 24. laura thanks for coming on this
morning
thank you you're welcome hi everyone i'm
brian kilmeade i want you to do me a
favor i want you to click to subscribe
to the fox news youtube page this is the
only way that i know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on fox
you can get it all here on youtube so
subscribe right now